Shiran Melamdovsky Somech, how are you?
I'm great, thank you.
And it's finally it's great to meet you.
Really good to be here. First of all,
did I say your name correctly?
Actually, yes.
Okay. So, all the rehearsing
that we did before this paid off.
Shiran, I can't wait for this conversation
because we have so much to talk about.
From your work at DRIVE TLV
to the two communities
that you are a part of,
Yazamiyot and Saleet.
Really incredible incredible missions.
And I'd love to talk
both about your day job,
but also your night job,
as you referred to it.
And some of the impact
that you're making on women
in Israel and the world.
So, maybe you can take me back
a little bit and give me a little bit
of an overview of what you do
at DRIVE TLV and then transition into
what are these two other communities
that you are a big part of?
Sure. So, DRIVE, its Innovation Center
for smart mobility.
And we are working together
with eight different partners.
And what is so unique with our partner
that they create
a wide range of domains.
So, today, many people think
that mobility is related to automotive.
Maybe kind of a very narrow world.
But it's much much more than that.
And today, we are working
with our partners.
So many different domain.
It could be infrastructure,
industry 4.0, smart cities,
logistic and delivery.
Even marketing, insurance, and finance.
So, it's amazing.
So, what is the end mission?
For us, so, we are really focus and drive
to create competitive advantage
both for our partners and our startup.
And what does that tangibly mean?
So, you're sitting in Tel Aviv
and what does the organization actually do
with these partnerships
and with these startups?
So, in the first phase,
we create a friction with as many startup
in the Israeli ecosystem.
We know how to create a value
for them from day one.
It could be a business opportunity
with our partners
using our connection, knowledge.
We have a lot of workshop and meetup.
We bring people
from all over the world and so on.
Also, we agnostic to the startup stage.
Could be early stage, mature,
round A, round B,
and even public companies.
So, in the second phase,
we find some promising startups
and we offer them to sit
in our core workspace for free
for a few months.
We consider this mature due diligence.
So, they have the opportunity
to learn about us,
about our value and so on.
And then for us to learn about them.
About the team.
Their progress, their technology.
And the third
and the most important phase for them,
we have the Fastlane program.
This is a program that I'm running.
It's drive commercialization program.
And it's relevant
for cutting edge technology startups
and also, startups that relevant
to our partners needs.
And we are working pretty intense
with those startup during five months.
And we assist them to meet the market.
Because usually they are coming to us
when they are very familiar
with the technology,
but not too familiar with the market.
A true Israeli story.
Exactly.
And we have this process with the startup.
Also we have a parallel process
with the partner.
We work in pretty tight
with our partners as well.
We assist them to adapt
and adjust the technology.
And also, of course,
that we're working with a startup
and the corporate,
now we need to create the touch point
between those two.
And it's usually in regular days
before the covid.
So, we have a real show.
We visit our partner in the headquarter
in Japan, Sweden, and the US.
Yes, it was super amazing.
And we had a presentation
in front of the top executive,
the CEO, the CTO, top engineer.
And we create a consensus
to drive in the startup.
And after we build this consensus,
everyone say,
"Wow. Drive is so amazing."
"And such a great startup."
"We have to work with those."
Now, after the CEO say that,
so then it's easier to move forward
to the next stage.
And then we create a B2B
with relevant business unit.
And they're talking about the technology
and how to move forward.
And I mean, it's the collaboration.
So, very very strategic partnerships
between the start ups and helping them
get into this very mature market already.
With very very big players
that I'm guessing,
getting contracts with them
and getting them to come on board
is very very difficult.
And having somebody like DRIVE TLV
facilitate that communication
and that strategy
is something that I'm sure
it's very very helpful.
Before I ask the why,
I want to ask the how.
What is happening with mobility right now
in the world or in Israel
that you're seeing
some of the trends in 2020?
Obviously we have autonomous vehicles,
we have electric vehicles.
But what in the world of mobility
are we still missing
some interesting opportunities
that we hope to see soon?
So first, I will consider
to what's happened in those days.
We cannot ignore to the covid effect.
So, first of all,
the automotive is booming.
But probably only if you're a Tesla.
So, for the other companies,
there is a big slowdown
in the manufacture and sales as well.
Less attention to innovation
and working with startups also,
in some of the time.
However, we can recognize also
new opportunities.
Like there is a new normal.
We are not sure what is going to stay
and how the world is going to look like.
But for now, there is a new normal.
There is new challenges.
We call it opportunity.
The cliche for making lemonade.
But this is what we're trying to do.
We are trying to be proactive.
So, we recognize, for example,
that many fleets.
That there is a car that is just
standing there in a parking lot
with no use at all.
And we approach our startup
and we assist them
to adjust their technology.
So, for example,
we have a solar panel company
that now it protect the vehicle batteries.
And also, we recognize
there is the rental car, for example.
There is no use for a rental car today.
However, there is increase
in the demand for delivery.
So, we took this rental car together
with the startup and the system to use it
as a delivery vehicle.
And utilization of the fleet.
So, it's amazing.
For those startup
it's amazing opportunity.
Very very cool.
Okay. So, I want to make sure
that we leave enough time
to talk about the two other organizations,
which are just wonderful.
Talk to me a little bit
about Yazamiyot.
This great community of females
that are working together
to promote women in entrepreneurship
and leadership positions.
But tell me a little bit about,
first of all, Yazamiyot,
for the English speakers
means female entrepreneurs.
That's the name of the community?
Exactly.
It's not exactly international name.
But this is exactly
the meaning of Yazamiyot.
And it was established,
I think it was the first
and the leading community in Israel
for propelling forward female entrepreneur
in the high tech industry.
And establish like more than 10 years ago
by a serial entrepreneur
named Hilla Ovil-Brenner.
And what we do in Yazamiyot,
it's actually give
the female entrepreneur hooks.
We want to be productive
and to assist them.
To give them relevant tools
so they can build successful companies.
And we collaborate
with leading IT company
as the Google campus.
We create Google campus for moms
for our family maternity leave.
That instead of stay at home
and have a massage courses for babies,
they have the opportunity
to get some relevant tool
and follow their dream
and change the world.
And I remember that,
I think it was five or six years ago,
I came to the Google campus offices
back in the old location.
And I remember I walk in
and there is like 20, 30 moms
with their babies
sitting there on Google campus
working together.
It was incredible.
It was really incredible.
So, this is an amazing initiative.
And it also became worldwide in Google.
And now actually we finished
another accelerated program
for more mature startups.
This time there's no babies.
Just the entrepreneurs themselves.
And together with Microsoft.
And it was very interesting program.
This time we did it during the covid.
And so, we did mostly in during Zoom
or Google Meet, the Microsoft platform.
And I think that it was
a very very interesting period.
Because the female founder,
specifically in those time,
need a guidance and assistance.
Right.
So, talk to me a little bit more broadly
about female entrepreneurship in Israel.
Something that you're now very familiar
and involved with.
What are some of the trends
that you've seen
over the past decade or so,
and perhaps where are we today
and what do we hope to become
in a few years as Yazamiyot
is trying to move the needle there?
I think this is a very important question.
Today we are talking about
like 7% of female founder.
It's very low number.
Just a quick reminder,
we have 51% of the population.
And for my experience,
I recognize two main reason for that.
The first one, the gates to Silicon Valley
and to successful startup company,
start with have a funding.
So, usually startup in the early stage,
don't really have a product.
Don't really have a product market fit.
Don't have income or revenue or whatever.
So, usually the investment
is based on chemistry
between the founders
and the venture capital.
And because of there are mostly
9% of the investor are male,
so it's a bit more difficult for female
to build this trust and those chemistry
and to get funding.
Interesting.
So, just to recap.
What you're saying is
one thing that you've noticed
is because, the beginning of the cycle
is that the majority
of the venture capital partners
in Israel are males,
and they make their pre-seed
or seed investments primarily based
on the chemistry with the team.
Because there's still very little,
perhaps annual revenue.
It's still there is not necessarily
product market fit.
So, they based it off of chemistry.
And just traditionally,
usually male investors
will have a better chemistry
with male founders.
So, it sounds like what you're saying is
that the touchpoint is not just
in getting more female entrepreneurs,
it's actually also getting more
female venture capital partners
who will help drive that investment
into female founders, right?
Did I get that right?
Yes, totally.
You've got it right.
And this is one of the biggest barrier
for a female founder.
And the second one is also related
to what you just mentioned.
It's women don't have
enough technical skills.
There's not enough technical female.
So, also I heard some theory,
call it, the leaking pipe.
So, you start in the high school,
it's a 50% boys and girls
study the mathematics
and computer science and so on.
But then in the army,
and then in the university,
the number become much lower.
And then the IT company.
And this is reflect both
about the skills itself.
So, it's very important to have
this technical skills
in the technical companies.
And also in the network.
Women usually,
don't have the right network.
Yeah.
Women usually
don't have the right network
because they weren't part
of the technical units in the army.
And they usually
don't have been in the university
in the relevant studies and so on.
Okay. So, the first thing we talked about
was this idea that we need more women
in venture capital positions
to make those decisions.
To invest in female entrepreneurs.
But inherently, we also need
more female technical founders
that are coming in from this background
and they don't fall within the pipeline.
And I actually had
a few fascinating conversations
with female engineers on this show.
And very similarly,
they were talking about
this decision making process
in high school, especially in Israel,
you have to choose your path
right already in high school,
where you're going to be studying.
And so, that's a very interesting junction
before you go into the military.
And I want to leave enough time
to talk about Saleet.
Because it's a very, while it's similar,
I mean, the idea about helping females,
but it's on a very different level.
So, talk to me a little bit
about what Saleet is
and what you're trying to do over there.
So, Saleet is a nonprofit organization.
Power Tel Aviv municipality
and the government.
And it's to help women in prostitution.
So, it's kind of different phase.
Very different.
Yes. In my life.
And it was very important to me to,
this is a topic that were very important
to me to assist those female
that not equal and part of the society.
So, in Saleet,  in the first phase,
the first detect the prostitution,
the prostitute,
and then give them a shelter.
Like a kind of a protection,
basic and sleep.
Sleep over, grab some food,
hiding from their pimp or whatever.
And then after they build the trust,
they can offer them rehabilitation.
To offer them to some treatment.
It could be a psychologist treatment
or a personal group therapy.
And also give them some tool
to be integrate in the society again.
So, how do you even get started
with waking up and saying,
now I want to work on a nonprofit
that will help women in prostitution?
There's so many different issues.
I mean, what drove you specifically
to this issue that you said,
"Okay, this is what I want to start
spending my nights on."
Because you obviously have
a full time job.
You're very involve with Yazamiyot
yet you're taking on this another project,
which technically sounds like
another full time job.
This is very good question,
I'm not sure I have the answer for that.
I was always attract to assist women
in human trafficking,
sex trafficking and so on.
I never had the opportunity to do it.
I just read about this
and I was thinking how awful it is.
And now the world
and the society can make this happen.
Right.
And while I finish my degree
and I have some free time,
like people looking for hobbies,
so, I calls it my hobby.
Wow. That's whats inspiring.
Instead of going dancing
or do something else,
it was very interesting.
And this topic, I think,
is super important.
Because like those female,
and this is also something
I understand along the way.
In the beginning,
my state of mind was,
we should do the prostitution to be legal.
To make it legal.
To give them the rights.
They should pay fees and so on.
But after a while,
after I was more involved in Saleet
and understand what's happened
to those women, so, I understand that
they don't do it from choice.
It's not like a freedom
of the occupation stuff.
It's not.
Like most of them,
90% in their childhood,
they have like a self abuse.
So, it's not like the easy choice
to make easy money.
It's far away from that.
And I think society need to do something.
And to assist these women.
So, what is the vision
that you are seeing
in the coming years with Saleet?
The vision.
I wish that they're talking a lot
about a new regulation in this field.
And it's something that
it's look positive.
They're talking about it for a while.
And also it looks positive
for a while as well.
But there is no sustainable government,
so, it's very difficult.
But the regulation, I think is right.
And this is what we are talking about.
It's to prevent the prostitution at all.
Right.
But from the customer side,
to cut the demand.
If there is no demand,
so, no be prostitutes.
Right. Classic economics.
Yes.
That makes sense.
Well, I just want to say that,
it sounds like all the programs
that you're running along,
in your night job,
right after your day job with DRIVE TLV,
it's completely inspiring.
And I'm getting personally
a lot of inspiration.
Because I think that at the end,
you can feel the energy
that you're bringing to these programs
and saying that your hobby
is to help women in prostitution
through a nonprofit that you're making
a scalable impact,
I think that's wonderful and I think
it's such an incredible hobby to have.
Even if you can call it even a hobby.
But before we leave,
I have to ask you
the most important question.
I need three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Oh, tough one.
The hardest one.
Yeah. I think the first one is stamina.
Empowerment.
And people person.
Stamina, empowerment and people person.
Shiran, thank you again
for your generous time and effort.
It sounds like you're doing
really really fantastic things.
And I can't wait to see the impact
of both Yazamiyot and Saleet.
And to continue following your journey
in DRIVE TLV.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for the opportunity. Bye.
Take care.